you eavesdrop because that's what you
really learn about your kids I I carpool
Sadie and her little guy friend to
soccer every Thursday and now I have
three of them in the car but when it
used to be just the two of them the
conversations were just astounding I
mean like one time they're talking about
Peter Sellers movie the party you know
there's six I was like that's a sixteen
I was like but the other day I there's
so many and I like text the mom like
you're not gonna believe what your son
did right he goes Sadie do you know what
sex is and she goes no when he goes it's
when you're outside naked with your
ex-girlfriend why ex-girlfriend but
you're just outside yeah and you're just
happen to be naked yeah it's your ex
yeah and that's it that's X that's X
that's X another time we were they liked
when we park at the place we get there
early they like to go all the way in the
back of the truck and they play and
stuff and one time
Sadie started singing the song hello
from trolls I don't know if you know
this song but you know it's this one
character it's like very heartfelt hello
and at the end of this it's based on the
Lionel Richie yeah yeah yeah yeah and
there's this one part at the end where
the little character goes so she's
singing it and she's vibrato and
everything which she calls her adult
singing right and she gets to the end
and she stops and he goes you didn't say
the I love you part gets better she goes
I know any ghost ad do you know why
there's so many songs about romance
because it's a very strong feeling
because it's a very strong feeling
that's advert this is a very to stuff
I'm listening this is a six year this is
a six year old boy yes we know the hell
he's talking about
awesome he's like my favorite person
does he wear a ruffled shirt
it's a very strong feeling do you know
why there's so many songs not romance
said it was a very strong feeling
you